[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Christian Wheeler.
I teach a lot of courses on the topic of
leadership agility at Stanford GSB and
these are five takeaways from my course,
spontaneous management.
[MUSIC]
In Silicon Valley, a lot of companies
have the motto of failing fast, failing
frequently, but on a personal level, it
can be difficult for us to accept failure.
We often have a fear of looking stupid in
front of other people or making mistakes,
but an outsize fear of failure has
negative consequences for us as leaders.
A fear of failure can make
you avoid growth situations.
And it's only when we are at
the outer edge of our limits,
when we are encountering that failure
possibility that we are operating at
the peak of our abilities.
Failure is a step on the path to learning.
Secondly, dwelling on failure
takes you out of the situation so
you can't respond adaptively
to what the context gives you.
We have a motto in the class to be
comfortable being uncomfortable.
You will feel anxious in
a lot of situations, but
if you can learn to ease into that
feeling without dwelling on it,
you can respond most
adaptively in any context.
[MUSIC]
Human beings communicate through
a wide array of channels, and
only one of them is the verbal channel,
the words that people say.
Most in-person communication
happens through non-verbal signals.
It is through these signals that
we get the layers of meaning,
people's unstated beliefs, their comfort
level, their emotions, their status, and
it's critical for us as leaders to learn
how to interpret these non-verbal signals.
But it's also important for us to
understand that we are always giving off
these non-verbal signals whether or
not we intend to.
In our class, we teach you how
to broaden your range much
like an actor might learn to play
different roles so that you can
recruit the non-verbal behaviors that are
most adaptive to you in any given context.
[MUSIC]
Improvisational theater is
a foundation of this class, and
improvisational theater is
all about story telling.
Practically since the dawn of language,
human beings have been
telling one another stories.
And the narrative structure is a structure
through which we give context and
even our own lives a sense of meaning,
purpose, and journey.
Stories are emotional.
They allow the listener to develop
an empathetic response to the protagonist.
And research shows that stories can
be more compelling than rhetoric and
more memorable as well.
You may not think of yourself
as a skilled storyteller, but
you can learn these techniques.
Stories have a typical structure and
compelling stories have common
elements that can be taught.
If you can learn to turn
your facts into stories,
you can develop a deep and
enduring connection with your audience.
[MUSIC]
If you've read anything about improv, you
know the first rule of improv is yes, and.
The yes component means that we are taking
somebody's input and incorporating it, and
the and means that we are building
specifically on that idea.
And it is through this process that
an improv company can take a simple
suggestion like a relationship
between two people and
end up with a fully creative,
dramatic, full length, 90 minute play.
It is through incorporating others ideas
and building on them that you can end up
in creative places that
you never anticipated.
Many of us are resistant to yes, and type
of thinking, because we want to contain
the situation, we want to have a sense of
control over the direction that goes in.
So when we can learn to cede some
of that control, to incorporate and
build on others ideas,
we can generate breakthrough,
innovative, creative solutions.
When you learn to embrace spontaneity, to
relax into the moment, to be comfortable
being uncomfortable, you can be
authentic and present in the moment.
When you learn to let go of preconceived
notions you have about yourself, to let go
of expectations about others and the
context, then you can be fully present and
adaptively respond to what
the moment gives you.
This allows you to attend
to unspoken things.
It allows you to be responsive
to ideas in your environment,
to see connections between
ideas that others overlook.
It allows you to interact deeply and
authentically to build rapport and
achieve your goals.
[MUSIC]
Yeah, you can't be an improviser unless
you're willing to look like a complete
idiot in front of people on
an unpredictable schedule [LAUGH].
[MUSIC].